[Music]
[Applause]
let me bring in chris mannix the senior
writer nba writer for sports illustrated
play in tournaments starting tonight do
you think the uh playing tournament
good idea is are we uh in this for the
long haul
i think the play in tournament is one of
the best
ideas the nba has ever had and i say
that
not knowing the results of the playing
tournament and knowing
that if it continues moving forward we
are
highly unlikely to get lebron versus
steph curry
in for the warriors anyway or well not
really a one game playoff but
uh two games and lose type of situation
the rest of the regular season dan
was just so much more interesting
because of the playing tournament
you had less tanking because of the
playing tournament i had a conversation
with scott brooks of the wizards uh just
last night and
he was telling me that the fact the
play-in tournament existed
and that the wizards even though they
finished as the number eight seed
only had to theoretically get to ten
really enabled them
to keep their season going in late
february early march when it looked like
they were going to
to fall apart so i'm all in on this
version
of the play in tournament i think the
nba is all in on as well
what are the odds that the lakers could
lose two in a row here
in the playing tournament very slim
um you know golden state game will be
fun
and i think the warriors because they
have a sneaky good defense top five
in the nba could be more competitive
than people think but
i don't know the idea that the lakers
could lose to golden state
and then lose to the winner of memphis
versus san antonio that seemed seems far
fast there's part of me though den
that wants them to lose the golden state
so
they wind up back in the clippers side
of the bracket because that
incredible tank job the clippers did
against oklahoma city
in the last game of the season i mean
you have to really try hard to lose to
oklahoma city because they're trying
equally hard
to lose that game uh for the clippers to
lose
the way they did uh just to avoid the
lakers side of the bracket it'd almost
be poetic
for them to get the lakers ultimately in
the end well didn't denver
try to do the same thing
yeah but i look i don't look at denver
as
a true championship contender i think
it's a bad look for anybody
to lose to try to avoid a team on your
side of the bracket but the nuggets
without you all murray
they're a great story not a championship
contender they could easily get beat
in the first round the clippers are like
this yeah
they're the contender right kawhi
leonard paul george ad rondo
ty lue different dynamic i keep hearing
from everybody how this is the year of
the clippers and what do they do at the
end of the regular season
they intentionally lose to oklahoma city
dan
you played the game i i've i've seen
crazier things happen
than a team win or tie when down five
with seven seconds left
but with seven seconds left down five
the clippers just inbounded the ball and
ran out the clock like they were
intentionally
trying to lose that game i just i that
to me doesn't put
uh say a lot about a team's mental
toughness going into the postseason okay
i'm trying to understand though the
clippers are are they better than last
year i know they were in the bubble
but i don't know what like what happens
to kawhi leonard if the clippers
bow out early here wait what what's his
future in l.a
well it's a good question i mean people
in la
will tell you that kawhi's in this for
the long haul
that he didn't come to the clippers for
one or two years he came to finish his
career
in southern california but if they get
beat early
and look this maverick series not going
to be easy for them i mean dallas goes
into this series
with a measure of confidence i mean they
were playing well
prior to kristaps porzingis going down
in the bubble last year so they're going
into the series thinking look
porzingis is healthy tim hardaway jr a
candidate for sixth man
uh one of a decent third scoring option
they think they can win if the clippers
bow out i don't know
i mean kawhi is obviously a tough guy to
get a read on but i don't i certainly
don't think it would bode well
for the future of the clippers front
office if they can't get out of the
second round
uh for the second year in a row the mvp
ballot is going to look like what nicole
yokic is going to be at the top
i mean you start there i i think it will
be
a wide victory for jokic i filled up my
ballot
last night the only difficult choices
were two to five i mean jokic
um yes he's been the most durable of
players and yes that was a factor
but he posted astonishing numbers he
averaged three more assists per game
than steph curry
while only averaging a few fewer points
and just as important for me dan as i
was
kind of going through the the process
here uh when jamal murray went down
the nuggets didn't fold they won nine of
their next ten and a lot of that was on
nicole yokic so for me that was kind of
the last push
uh for jokic at uh at the top of the
ballot okay who's second
this is where i think it's going to get
subjective i had joel embiid
um i would have liked to have seen him
play a few more games
but the games he did play in he was
dominant and if he had played the same
number of games
as jokic he would be the mvp but i think
he did enough
to warrant second on my ballot third i
went with giannis
um massive numbers uh this season fourth
i went with luka doncic
um yeah the mavericks after a really
slow start they came on to finish with
that five seed and don just posted mvp
worthy
numbers and fifth was steph uh on my
ballot just an incredible scoring year
uh for curry and help push that team
into this playoff mix so those are my
top five with some very difficult
omissions okay
if there was an open draft and you could
have curry
or jokage this year
one one one season one season well
that's not how the mvp really works but
i i would i'd probably take jokic for
this season okay probably
yeah i don't think you believe that i
don't think you believe that i
like steph to me to steph
the you know the warriors without steph
win what
15 games 12 games probably
probably something that's not good it's
not pretty yeah but
it's not like they you know if they were
higher than the eighth seed i might have
a different opinion on this but it's not
like they set the league on fire
with how they played yes in the game
steph played and they were great too
like they're a better record of games he
played in
uh than the ones that he didn't but i
mean i just made the case for jokic
after murray went down they lost an
all-nba point guard
and they won nine of their next ten like
that matters in this uh
okay all right i'm just i i i was on
record as saying steph would win the mvp
from the start of the season right and
and figuring that maybe they would have
klay thompson and then
maybe they would have james wiseman but
i thought that he did a
incredible job so he did so look leaving
i mean the guys you leave off are just
as tough i mean damian lillard
leaving him off the top five yeah uh you
know chris paul
leaving him off the top five i mean
there's a lot of guys that made it tough
to vote
we're talking to chris mannix sports
illustrated nba senior writer
uh which team is in better shape the
knicks or the celtics
that's a tough one um
i i gotta go with boston only because
their top two players are better and
have more
upside than the knicks top two players
it i mean the knicks this season has
been remarkable but i'd still
take tatum and brown over
randall and rj barrett so long term i
look at boston there needs to be some
kind of
substantive change there i mean if that
boston team dan loses
in the next two games to fall completely
out of the playoff picture
i wouldn't be surprised i think they
lose to washington tonight
and it wouldn't surprise me if they lost
to the winner of charlotte
uh and new orleans and indiana they've
got to do something
significant but long term i still like
the
the talent gap between tatum and brown
and
whatever the next can throw out there
but if they lose the next two
brad stevens is still safe yes brad
stevens who signed
i believe a five-year contract um just
uh last year
he's still safe i i just wonder i mean
is danny ainge
going to stick around i mean that's a
question i have um
you know danny's been the gm in boston
for almost 20 years now
that's an incredibly long period of time
for any top executive
i don't think danny's in a trouble i
don't believe that ownership would would
push him out or he'd be fired for any
reason
but at some point you just kind of say
all right well i've done enough i led
this team to a championship
i put it in a good position it's i don't
have the same energy for the job anymore
that's something i i wonder about as we
head into the celtics off season
before i let you go i know you also
cover boxing for sports illustrated
why is boxing so gimmicky now that we
actually
care about some internet tick-tock
star you know fighting floyd mayweather
or so-called
like that why is this a big deal
well i would say this boxing fans don't
care it's just that
they've been able to marshal the
legion of followers that followed them
on
tick tock and youtube and instagram and
all over the place and convince
that group of people to buy
pay-per-views
which is a credit to logan paul and jake
paul and
all the other youtubers that are out
there trying it i don't think boxing
fans are pivoting
to these youtube guys i just think
they've been able to bring an entirely
new audience
into the boxing space which in a strange
way could turn out to be good for boxing
if they handle it in the right way now
you put a quality fight
on the undercard of logan paul versus
floyd mayweather it exposes them
to an entirely new audience now boxers
that get frustrated by the numbers that
these youtubers are doing
they just have to look in the mirror i
mean boxing nowadays dan
how many times do we get the best
fighting the best how many fights
fall by the wayside because of boxing
politics you want to draw the same type
of crowd
and draw do the same type of numbers as
these youtube guys stop fighting
nobodies
fight top level opponents and boxing
fans will come back
in droves i've long believed dan that
all the tens of thousands of fans that
showed up at the sugar ray leonard
fights and the mike tyson fights
and the linux lewis fights all
throughout previous decades they're
still there
they're just waiting for good fights to
happen i was down in texas
where they had 73 000 people in a t
stadium which may not have been the
safest thing in the world to do but they
had 73 000 people
in that stadium for canelo alvarez
against billy joe saunders
if you build it they will come if you
put on good fights
they will come back right now they're
not putting on good fights and the
youtube stars
are claiming a piece of that audience i
would be interested if floyd mayweather
fought both
brothers then i would be interested in
that bout
simultaneously do you still even care
like
i mean yes okay wwe style you know
handicap match i guess
fine whatever but it floyd fighting
logan paul is gonna have like 35 pounds
on him
logan paul is not going to get a glove
on him not a single glove unless floyd
lets him and decides to give the fans a
show by taking a shot or two but
otherwise uh if you're paying for it go
right ahead it's your money do whatever
the hell you want with it but don't
expect
logan paul to do anything that resembles
being competitive with floyd mayweather
great to talk to you chris thanks for
joining us you got it dan
that's chris mannix senior nba and
boxing writer for sports illustrated